don't want to end this week we have a  jazz to Candyman and you're gonna dancer  the Candyman so I decide what better way  to get inspiration and eating candy  [Music]  Allen he's awesome he's super outgoing  he's definitely been a really good  reflection for me to not take myself so  seriously  we're doing police work you yeah for  cute dork  so much fun to dance with someone that  you have a connection with it's almost  like time slows down we communicate not  just through our steps and our movements  but with our hearts too I am developing  feelings for Alan and  [Music]  I didn't see this one coming but it  happened really quickly though so I  think I'm still trying to process it  [Music]  [Applause]